the whole economy spent 10 years getting
used to zero percent interest rate so
you have an entire economy that was
financed at zero percent basically that
now has to refinance everything going
forward at five six seven eight percent
that's a messy process the question now
is how long can this go on
all right guys bang bang I thought a
great place to start this conversation
was around inflation you and I
previously have talked about inflation
and kind of was it actually higher than
the official numbers now maybe people
are thinking it might be lower than the
official numbers just give us kind of
your perspective what is inflation today
and what are you paying attention to
when people start talking about that
specific metric the main reason why I
think anybody probably knows who I am in
the first place is because during the
financial crisis I was hyper focused on
a lot of this stuff because I manage
money for other people and I was trying
to get I I really didn't care about like
the the political narratives around this
or how to solve the problem so much as
much as I really wanted to understand
what's going on at sort of an
operational level so that I can then try
to navigate this knowing kind of this
Baseline Foundation of how does the
system work and how does this stuff
really work at like an operational level
so like the analogy that I use a lot of
the times is like understanding how a
car works when you understand how just
like an internal combustion engine works
and like the pedals and the gear
shifters work you can then begin to
build sort of a framework for what are
the parameters within which that that
automobile can actually operate you know
like can it go 300 miles an hour you
know because you hear a lot of these
sort of crazy narratives about this
stuff where it's like well wait a minute
like that's not actually how this works
the car can't actually go 300 miles an
hour it's literally functionally not
capable of doing that in this sort of an
environment and so you know the the
thing that makes finance and economics
so sort of cool and interesting is that
you have a driver in that car so it's
not just the automobile it's like you've
got like sometimes you've got crazy
people inside driving the car and it's
like okay well this thing's only capable
of doing certain things but also
it could do irrational things because
you've got you know stupid people or
just people that are overreactive and
hyper-emotional steering that vehicle so
I went back like during the financial
crisis and you know when everything was
starting to really get crazy and I'm
researching how the monetary system
works at like a very operational level
and it's crazy to think like back you
know 13 14 years ago online there just
was not a lot of information about how
the system works at like a very sort of
Baseline operational level like people
weren't explaining what is quantitative
easing how does it work how does fiscal
policy work how does government spending
interact with quantitative easing and so
I was sort of kicking the tires on all
this stuff and building a framework for
trying to understand it and so from a
very sort of Baseline understanding I
think it's it's crucial to understand
how the government thinks about a lot of
this stuff because the government's the
one that obviously sets all the policies
so their debt definitions and their
parameters for how a lot of the stuff
works is what matters the most in my
view and so from an inflationary
perspective inflation is a basically a
continuous increase in the price of a
basket of goods and so the Bureau of
Labor Statistics will go out and they
put together a basket of basically all
different items that they think is
reflective of like the average household
purchases and this thing they updated it
changes all the time the methodologies
are I think I mean flawed at best
um
wrong at worst you know so and and you
know to be fair to them that's true of
probably most inflation metrics I mean
you're not ever because everyone's
inflation experience is different for
instance I mean like my inflation
experience is totally different from
somebody who lives in Texas or you know
in a foreign country or I mean literally
every buddy so
it's very hard to pin this down and so
we're talking about flawed metrics that
are that are averages on you know for
for the majority of the population and
the the Bureau of Labor Statistics is
just trying to give us I think an idea
of where prices are in general and so
you know the last few years were super
super interesting in large part because
I mean covid was just such a strange it
was such a strange event and I think I
remember talking to you in 2020 talking
about how inflation was likely to be
higher than people expected and how the
Fed was going to get caught off guard by
it and a big part of that is that the
way that they measure this stuff is
inherently sort of either it's rear view
mirror looking or at best they're
looking you know they're looking out the
side mirrors you know they they kind of
see a lot of what's going on around them
but they're not in a position where
they're really trying to drive this
vehicle primarily by looking through the
the windshield basically and as an asset
manager I can't afford to be driving the
vehicle by looking at the rear view
mirror first off I have to be trying to
understand what's coming down the pike
here and so
povid was really crazy because covet in
a lot of ways was very different from my
experience with the great financial
crisis where a lot of people know me
from the financial crisis as being a
deflationist and basically really
vocally saying that everything that's
going on in the financial crisis was
inherently deflationary because it was a
it was what economists would call a debt
deflation meaning that basically people
bought so much debt in the pre-crisis
period that when asset prices started to
fall people started to pay back all of
their loans and
we can kind of get into money supply
Dynamics if you want to later but
basically in a in a really General
framework the way that the money supply
in a Fiat monetary system increases and
decreases is that loans create money
loans create deposits so when people are
borrowing a lot the money supply is
increasing a lot the government can also
increase the financial asset Supply we
can talk about that too later but when
people repay loans that destroys money
so it's inherently this distance or
deflationary or disinflationary meaning
a a falling rate of inflationary process
and so the financial crisis was
inherently deflationary because you had
balance sheets where all shrinking
basically and the kicker with this is
that the FED responded with a great big
bazooka and the FED primarily operates
through rescuing Banks basically the FED
is a bank for banks so everything they
do kind of filters through the banking
system so they did a they did a bang-up
job of say saving all their buddies at
the banks but the problem was really at
the consumer level and consumers were
suffocating from basically a balance
sheet depression and the the big
difference with covid is that during the
financial crisis there was not a big
fiscal policy response so there wasn't a
huge amount of government spending that
came out of that there was we passed
like an 800 billion dollar rescue
package if you remember but um in in the
grand scheme of things it seemed big at
the time but it really wasn't that big
especially compared to covet and I think
that was really the big lesson coming
out of covert was when I started seeing
the the size of these packages that were
coming out it was like well wait a
minute we're gonna do we're gonna do a
two to three trillion dollar deficit
this year which means basically they're
spending more than their taxing and that
that extra deficit spending in my
framework has been as thought of as you
can call it deficit money printing I
think in essence because the the
government is issuing
super safe money-like instruments when
they run a deficit so deficits are money
Printing and the size of the deficits
were so big in covid I mean they ended
up God I mean after we talked they did
like two more huge packages so this like
kept going and going by the time that by
I mean the by the beginning of 2022 it
was like seven trillion dollars of
deficits inside of like a two and a half
year period which is
I mean we're talking colossally huge
numbers here
and so you know the interesting thing
with in concordance with like
quantitative easing was that well we did
all the same stuff in 2008 with
quantitative easing the Fed ramped Up
their balance sheet in a huge way
everybody called it money printing but
the difference between covid and the the
GFC was that the government spent a hell
of a lot more money and so to me that
was sort of the big aha moment when I
started to see the the really the size
of the government package and the
composition of it it wasn't so much oh
the FED is doing a lot of stuff because
the FED did a lot of stuff back in the
GFC and it you know inflation never
really like got out of control or it
never really got high and actually for
the next 10 years basically continued to
go down down until we you know we ended
up with basically permanent zero
interest rates because inflation was so
low and so but following the the GFC or
sorry following the covid pandemic the
policies were so huge and at the same
time the government is basically saying
stay home don't work don't make anything
here's a bunch of money so it was like
it was like the perfect recipe for you
know inflation 101 where the government
prints a ton of money you get supply
constraints not only because governments
are telling people not to go to work but
because of all these other quirky
problems with covid and so you know you
get more money chasing fewer goods and
here we are so you know that's kind of
the you know the transition of what's
happened over the course of the last two
three years so there's a brand new book
um or relatively new over the last
couple years by Edward Chancellor uh
called the price of time and it talks
about interest rates and I actually
enjoyed the first half of the book
better because it goes back over the
history of interest and interest rates
and one of the stories that they tell in
there is uh John Law and the Mississippi
company and basically it was a guy who
had this whole you know economic theory
that uh you could go and do a whole
bunch of experimentation and you
wouldn't actually drive inflation Etc
now short story is at one point he was
the richest man in history he claimed uh
and then he ended up broke because the
entire company fell apart but what came
out of that was as they were trying to
create paper currencies and print money
and kind of do all these
experimentations inflation exploded and
so I use that as an example like we're
talking centuries ago we have that
example and we've seen it time and time
and time again throughout history where
inflation occurs when they print money
why is it that we haven't learned the
lesson is it because we want to kind of
address the short-term pain and don't
care about the long-term costs at the
moment or is there something else going
in there that humans are just really
stupid and we don't learn history like
what's going on
you know
so the
the way that we we print money is it's
nothing new really I mean Fiat money
like a lot of people talk about Fiat
money as if it's like something that you
know really just started to exist in
like you know the 1970s or something or
got out of control in the 1970s and
really like the way I like to think of
it is that
money money is inherently credit any
Financial system I think will enhance
and it will inherently turn into a
credit based system where even in the
the oldest of old monetary systems like
the Code of Hammurabi talks about how
Farmers would create credit contracts
where you know one farmer basically
would have a lot of seeds and another
farmer needed seeds to plant his farm
and so the rich farmer says you know hey
poor farmer here is a here's 10 seeds
you can go and you can multiply this
into your new Farm oh but here's a
contract where you owe me 11 seeds next
year as repayment and that contract
essentially it's a credit contract but
that contract is functionally money-like
and that's become as sort of economies
have evolved over time those contracts
that we think of as credit have evolved
into money so like in a modern monetary
system the majority of the money that we
all use is Bank deposits and Bank
deposits primarily come from loan
creation so you know I go out I borrow
money to to get a mortgage to purchase a
home and that loan creates a deposit and
that deposit you know in the in the the
Hammurabi days that contract was
probably it was worthless except between
the two farmers but in a modern system
that contract has become money basically
in the sense that anybody can now take
that contract and go anywhere and use it
as money because it's exchangeable for
basically anything it's not just
exchangeable for seeds now you can go
into you know Home Depot and Walmart and
you know go on Amazon and use those
deposits that contract basically to buy
whatever you want because it's it's
money-ness you know the I like to use
the term moneyness in the sense that
every every instrument we use whether
it's Bitcoin or you know bonds or
30-year treasury bonds or gold or all
these different instruments have a
certain degree of moneyness but Bank
deposits have
I would argue the if not an
extraordinarily high level of money is
the absolute highest moneyness and so
all of these loans that create deposits
are now money in the sense that you can
go out and you can they're fungible for
for basically anything and so in in a
modern monetary system the creation of
credit I think is a is sort of the
Natural Evolution of just the way that
all markets have all financial markets
have always worked across time because
you always have people that have demand
for money and you always have people
that you know either have more assets or
more money that are willing to say hey
you know what I don't need this I'll
give you a little bit and maybe you can
go out and you can do something good
with it and you can repay me with a
little bit more in the future and
so you know in a weird sort of sense you
know you don't want to I don't want to
call it a like a pyramid scheme or Ponzi
like because the system does really rely
on a Perpetual sort of increase of
credit over time
but the there's a ponzi-like aspect to
it when you're not creating the when
you're not creating the seeds like if
that farmer just goes out and you create
this contract and the other farmer just
goes out and you know takes a dump in
the piece of paper and buries it in the
dirt and forgets about it well you know
that's the part where this all gets
really problematic because when you're
just sending money out to people and no
one's doing anything no one's building
anything that becomes Ponzi like in the
sense that you're not creating the real
resources that actually support that
contract because that contract is only
viable if the guy if the farmer actually
plants the seeds and produces that 11th
seed to be able to you know repay back
to the original farmer it's the thing
that makes the whole system work and so
I always like to say that the creation
of debt is on a balance sheet level it's
the creation of an asset and a liability
there's nothing really inherently good
or bad about that it depends on how it's
being used and a lot of the times you
know debt is used in really good ways
like people borrow money all the time to
build great companies or build homes and
I mean actually Building Homes is the
primary thing that we do with debt is we
go out and we build useful Big Blocks of
wood that are you know real resources
and so when you're doing things like
that
I don't think there's anything
necessarily problematic about the
creation of more money over time because
you're creating things that give that
money value they back that money whereas
when you're just Doling out money and
people are you know just sitting around
you know having Zoom calls for fun and
playing video games and you know crap
like that it's like well of course
that's inflationary you're not creating
the real resources that actually support
the money in the first place so and I
think you know that's a really
contentious discussion because you get
into like these political discussions
about well oh well you know these this
group of people they don't have enough
so you know why can't we we take some
money and redistribute it to these
people or you know and then you know a
lot of the times the people that have
the money will say well you know why I
worked hard for this you know I borrowed
money when I was young and poor and I
built something great like why should I
have to give up what I've produced and
earned over time and potentially harm my
family and my future generations and
Offspring just to benefit somebody else
you get into all these contentious
political debates about how this works
and so a lot of the times the government
just comes in and says you know what
screw having to try to tax rich people
or whatever it is we'll just print the
money and give it to this group of
people that need it for whatever purpose
so what's fascinating to me about this
is we have on one side of this like debt
GDP uh equation is the debt and I think
a lot of people are focused there
obviously we have the debt limit crisis
that has started to get a lot of
attention hopefully that's being averted
we have the national debt kind of
hitting these absurd numbers it probably
will hit another all-time high as soon
as the debt limit is increased and they
just keep on right borrowing
um but there is like the GDP side and
the economic growth side and so what is
fascinating to me is uh two things one
when you go and you look in history what
you find is uh that there's actually
been economic growth during deflationary
times not every time but but there has
been growth uh at certain points
um which would pull into question this
idea of like you need inflation in order
to Spur economic growth but the second
thing is that there's a bunch of things
that we do in society whether it is
taking on more debt in the nature that
we do whether it's some of the stock
buyback stuff whatever where we are
doing things that create the illusion of
wealth but it doesn't necessarily drive
more economic growth and so it calls
into question kind of like how well do
we actually understand the relationship
between debt and economic growth
yeah
it's part of what makes
especially periods like the covet
experience relatively frightening
because I really don't think anybody
understands like what is the limit here
you know what is the point where
inflation turns into something that
you know is just sort of uh like I like
to think of you know something like a
zero to two percent rate of inflation is
generally not that problematic it's not
I mean you can have zero to two percent
inflation and living standards can
increase I mean that's basically the
experience of the United States over the
last you know hundred and hundred or so
years I mean inflation you know you look
at a chart of like the the purchasing
power of the dollar you know it's just
gone you know down 97 or whatever but
the kicker with this is that living
standards have in Fault I mean American
living standards objectively by
by most metrics have increased despite
this purchasing power Decline and that's
in large part because we are a hugely
productive economy we create the goods
and the resources that despite the
decline in the the dollar purchasing
power we're better off in in terms of
our real resources I mean if you'd
invested a hundred dollars in the S P
500 back in 1900
it would have turned into something like
forty thousand dollars by now versus you
know if you'd left your money in the
mattress it's you know now it's it's
purchasing power and that's in real
terms you know so inflation adjusted
terms if you'd left your money in the
mattress and you'd been the person that
produced nothing you know your
purchasing power fell by 97 so that's
the difference between using money in a
productive manner versus just letting it
sit around and you know basically lose
purchasing power over time so you know
it's this um
it's this weird sort of situation where
I think that some level of of small
inflation is not necessarily bad for
long-term living standards but the the
thing that's disconcerting in all of
this is that we don't really know the
level where you reach kind of like an
escape velocity on this and it becomes
really problematic where you know you
get to like four percent inflation and
then 10 inflation and when does 10
inflation then start to sort of you know
reach an escape velocity where you get
20 30 40 inflation and then then your
economy is really really effed
um and we don't you know the evidence is
so it's so different across different
regimes I wrote a paper in 2011 where I
identified that basically most
hyperinflations occur under very like
fairly specific regimes it's it's
usually a catastrophic loss of
production for some reason season a war
and government regime changes and so
when you get these very sort of seismic
shifts in geopolitical events you
oftentimes get a very very high rate of
inflation and so
you know typically at least in the last
50 years there has not been a
hyperinflation in a credit-based
monetary system without one of those big
problems occurring at the same time and
so but at the same time we really don't
know the level where
you know like you could argue that
if the government had continued to print
three four trillion dollars every year
and just telling people to stay home you
would have at some point during all of
this you would have had a catastrophic
decline in production because people
would have been like you know f it I'm
I'm not going to make anything I'm
getting a check every month in the mail
from the government so I'm just going to
stop producing stuff and at some point
you would have gotten the deficit would
have caused this catastrophic decline in
production that probably would have
resulted in if not a much higher rate of
inflation than we got something like a
higher a hyperinflation but we we really
it's inflation is still such a
it's so economically specific to the way
each I think country operates
and and the way each government works as
well that it's very very hard to pin
down what's the causation here exactly
and what's the point where this becomes
really problematic and it's it's super
kind of disconcerting when you
understand this from like a like the
fed's perspective or the government's
perspective because dude I don't think
they have any idea either like they this
two percent inflation Target that they
have
that's like a it's a number that some
politician in Australia mentioned in the
media like 10 years ago and then all the
other Central Bankers were like hmm yeah
that seems like a pretty reasonable
number let's all use that like that's
literally how the the two percent
inflation Target came to be so nobody
knows which is really it it is one of
the things that's really disconcerting
what's fascinating about this is Paul
volcker who obviously stepped in and
jacked up interest rates to fight
inflation in the 80s he actually has
come out and said nowhere in his
textbooks was two percent in there and
he thinks it's a stupid rule right or a
kind of stupid guiding uh measurement it
also brings into going back to
Chancellor's book uh goodheart's law
which is like anything that was uh so
anything that was a measure that now
becomes a goal ceases to be a good
measure and so if you are actually
looking at this the inflation uh kind of
uh issue you mentioned that the central
Bankers may not know and I do think that
this is somewhat uh interesting because
Central Banking is a confidence game if
all of a sudden we all woke up tomorrow
we're like we have zero confidence in
them to do this a lot of things would
change people would change their
behaviors obviously we saw with Silicon
Valley Bank and some of these Banks we
went and withdrew money very quickly
um and so the system changes things
break whatever
but by being human and having the
unknowable future as part of what you're
trying to underwrite and then also
having to admit that you're using
backwards looking data to make current
decisions and try to predict what the
future impact is going to be it's
impossible and so
what do you think the solution could be
the other crazy thing about this is that
especially with the fed the FED is super
data dependent so the fed you know
they're beholden to treasure to Congress
basically and so when they do stuff they
they don't have the ability to to have a
lot of discretion in the same way that
like I do managing a portfolio
um in large part because they have to be
able to look at evidence and they have
to be able to go to explain to Congress
hey we did this for this reason like
look look at the data at this moment in
time and we knew that this is what was
going on and so this is what we decided
to do and so they have to be able to
justify all this stuff and so
like right now is a really interesting
time because a lot of fed officials are
looking at like the 1970s as the
playbook for for what might happen and
they're not considering necessarily that
this is a completely unknown environment
completely different from anything we've
ever experienced because of what just
happened with covid but they're using
this like 1970s Playbook to manage the
risks potential going forward and so
they're very worried about like an
Arthur Burns moment where like you know
the the Fed eases Up and then inflation
takes off again and you get this policy
error that results in you know a
basically a lost decade of super high
inflation but a lot of that is based on
you know not just rear view looking
historical data but the fact that right
now they're being super cautious with
the way that they're moving forward in
large part because they're they're
looking at current indicators basically
and they're saying well inflation is
still high relative to our Target rate
and in order to manage the risk there we
have to we don't want to do anything too
extreme so they're cautious about moving
really aggressively because they're they
also know the experience of the you know
the financial crisis where a lot of the
stuff that was going on then obviously
was deflationary so they're they're
looking at all this basically coincident
indicators and they're saying okay well
inflation right now based on our
readings is like five percent let's say
so we're going to leave the overnight
rate at five percent until we get a
better idea of what's going on like
I mean they're going to wait they're so
data dependent because they're beholden
to Congress that they have to wait on
all this data to come out like they're
going to wait for this week's labor
report the the employment reports coming
out
um tomorrow it's we're recording this on
a Thursday so it's coming out on a
Friday morning and this data
which first of all it's
completely rear view mirror looking too
because this is these are surveys from
last month and these are surveys that
they get updated multiple multiple times
in the future so you could get like a
you can get a reading tomorrow of like
250 000 jobs created and the government
will come out in like six months and say
oh yeah you know that may reading
um it wasn't actually 250 000 it was
actually minus 250 000 after all of our
revision and so it's this crazy sort of
system where they're looking at either
coincident data or or you know rear view
looking mirror data to make current
decisions rather than using some sort of
model that is at least somewhat
forward-looking
when we start thinking about the fed's
activities I remember this quote that uh
Jerome Powell had uh kind of in the
height of inflation really starting to
take off so it was already over five
percent
um and the only reason I remember this
is because I think I spent like two
hours ranting about it one day but
somebody asked them like you know are
you worried about uh the impact on
economic inequality uh given how high
inflation is going and he basically said
something which again I want to be fair
to him like I think it was kind of like
an offhand comment but when put into
print it sounded really bad and he was
like like no one's come into my office
and told me uh that like you know
they're falling behind
and you know we went on this huge rant
and like dude what do you want people to
like show up to your office and like
navigate the halls of the FED like you
know like come on it's like a ridiculous
thing but put aside for a second like
all the comedy and and like the
hilariousness of the question and the
the answer
um the health of the consumer is
actually like a pretty important part of
this right like they're not blind to the
fact that yes they're trying to address
inflation they're trying to address some
of this stuff they claim to not really
care that much about asset prices
themselves but I do think they probably
pay attention to it we right now are
seeing savings rate completely depleted
we're seeing credit card debt Spike to
you know near all-time highs interest
rates on that credit card debt is
spiking pretty high how do you think
about the health of the consumer in
light of you know fed policy inflation
and some of this interest rate stuff
it's worrisome in large part because
you I've talked about this in a lot of
recent interviews that I've done where
what's going on right now is it's
playing out when you think of credit
Cycles the basic way that a credit Cycle
Works is you get so in 2008 we get this
big bust balance sheets compress the FED
gets super easy they reduce interest
rates the government spends a little bit
of money puts money in people's pockets
the economy slowly starts to recover you
know the unemployment rate Falls a lot
and as as demand sort of picks up you
start to get more and more people coming
into the labor force and people then
start borrowing more and more companies
start borrowing more to build more
whatever it is and all of this is this
very sort of cyclical thing where for
then for 10 years you had people
borrowing at very very low interest
rates and you know adding to other
people's incomes because borrowing adds
to other people's incomes when people
spend that borrowing and the credit
cycle then is is recovering people are
people are borrowing more the economy is
growing modestly and then covet happens
and all the craziness there you got and
the government basically like said okay
now everybody here's here's money for
you and you and you and you and go out
and go crazy and you know live your life
and stay home and you know don't don't
build anything and so you got this crazy
jump in prices you know at the same time
that the government technically was
issuing a huge amount of credit and all
of this results in this High rate of
inflation that we're seeing now and then
the problem is
is that the FED then wakes up to it and
the FED says well wait a minute
inflation is way too high and now we
need to slam the brakes on all this so
they raise rates faster than they've
ever raised rates in history coming off
of zero going to five it's never
happened as fast as they did it and it
causes all sorts of problems in like
more your average mortgage payment went
from like like the old rule for
financial planning used to be you spend
like spend like 28 of your your income
on shelter and now the cost of a
mortgage is is basically equal to like
50 percent of income so incomes haven't
gone up that much and the FED has made
things so expensive from a credit Market
perspective that being able to afford
credit now is I mean you have in the
last few years there's like 50 million
people that have been completely priced
out of the housing market just because
of the mortgage rate situation and the
FEDS jacking of interest rate so quickly
so you've got this we're in this weird
sort of like Wily coyote moment where
you know we've jumped off the cliff and
now we're up there and people are trying
to maintain their living standards
relative to to where covid placed
everything because covid repriced
everything in such a way where now
people are basically forced to borrow
more to maintain their living standards
because incomes haven't risen at the
same rate of inflation and so it's a
it's a really sort of problematic
environment because the question now is
how long can this go on how long can
people continue to borrow at the rate
that they're borrowing and continue to
sustain the economy in a way where you
either don't get
a recession or at you know like my view
basically has been that the economy is
decelerating and was going to just be
like I've called it a muddle through
basically it's not going to be you're
not going to have like a crisis period
coming out of this but you're also
definitely not going to have like a boom
period And so it's going to be just sort
of this period of struggle where
people's real disposable income is
struggling to keep up with their ability
to actually continue to buy the things
that not just are Necessities but the
things that are luxuries and
so it's this it's this weird sort of
environment where I would argue that the
longer the FED stays really really
aggressive trying to fight all this the
the more that creates the risk of
probably a downside event
um maybe not like a 2008 but something
that is you know at minimum a recession
at worst probably a you know a credit
event that occurs
who knows whether it's in the commercial
real estate market or the consumer
Market we're obviously already seeing it
happen in the banking system to some
degree but
um you know at some point things start
to if not break completely they start to
crack a lot in this sort of an
environment because you have this this
discrepancy between the way that the the
overnight interest rate works and the
availability of credit versus what
people have become accustomed to and
that's a big part of this is that people
the whole economy spent 10 years getting
used to zero percent interest rate so
you have an entire economy that was
financed at zero percent basically or
very low interest rates that now has to
refinance everything going forward at
five six seven eight percent that's a
messy process
I keep coming back to this idea that uh
pretty much anyone under the age of 40
give or take uh majority of their career
if not their entire career has been in
that zero interest rate environment like
there is a good portion of the current
capital allocators business owners uh
you know Founders Etc they've never had
to think about this other world they
have no experience in this other world
and that doesn't mean that they're not
smart and uh kind of can iterate quickly
and learn it and talk to people read
books you know listen to podcasts
whatever and like get up to speed it's
just that like their experience is
rooted in that very very low interest
rate environment and so maybe we return
back to that and like it's okay and it
was just like hey a one or two year
period where they had to kind of figure
it out but if we stay in an elevated
interest rate environment you basically
gotta re-teach an entire generation
right of people how to build businesses
and allocate Capital given that interest
rate being at a higher level
it's
and it's much much harder to operate in
that sort of environment than it is in
the easy money environment where anybody
you know or not not anybody but you know
a lot more people were able to obtain
financing and Credit in that environment
I mean I
I feel horrible for a lot of people who
wanted to buy homes over the course of
the last five years who now you know
after the huge price surge in real
estate combined with the the jump in
mortgage rates I mean these people who
knows when they're going to be able to
afford to buy a home I mean I my basic
view going forward is that
I think that the the modern system and
the the way that the credit structure of
the entire macro economy is built from
the last 10 years
it's not sustainable to just jump up to
seven percent mortgage rates and then
say okay this is the new normal I think
at some point something has to happen or
things return at least to a somewhat
more normal environment where you end up
with
you know will they go to zero again I
don't think the FED will I think the
fed's gonna be hesitant to go to zero
unless something really really
frightening happens in the next few
years I find it hard to believe they're
going to go to zero again but I think
the FED wants to be at like a two to
three percent overnight interest rate
which that's equivalent to like uh
probably like a five percent mortgage
rate which you know to me if inflation
is falling to like let's say inflation
comes down to like anything even
remotely close to their target two to
three percent something like that I
think then they can start to justify
reducing interest rates a little bit and
then things start to normalize and at
least then in that environment you've
got things are still obviously a lot
more difficult in credit markets than
they were with zero percent interest
rates but it's not this situation where
I mean they've they've really nuked the
housing market for tens of millions of
of Americans and so I don't and I don't
think they want that I think they just
know that it's a necessary evil to go
through the process of bringing
inflation down they're trying to reduce
demand for credit and new money issuance
in a way where you do it long enough
eventually either the economy we get
this so-called soft Landing or you get a
situation where something breaks and if
something breaks you know they're gonna
they're gonna reduce interest rates and
bring things back down to that situation
much much faster than they otherwise
would
how does the banking crisis play into
all of this like obviously that seems to
be in some ways a corralled kind of uh
acute situation if you talk to another
crowd of people they're like no this is
literally every bank is insolvent and
like we're screwed unless the FED steps
in and continues to be persistent which
is inflationary like how do you just see
that banking crisis playing into all
this
so it's kind of two things I think part
of it is that it's
it's evidence of the bigger problem
where the banks are the banks are having
trouble adjusting to this new normal
where
I mean three four years ago a bank could
you know borrow it zero and lend it
three and that was the basic business
model now and they and again they they
went through 10 years of building their
balance sheets off of that model whereas
all of the sudden within a year the FED
goes from zero to five and now that
banking model is broken to a larger
degree because now banks in order to
maintain that same margin what they're
trying to do is they're borrowing at
five and they're trying to lend at eight
and the problem is is there's not a lot
of people out there that want that eight
percent rate or people that can afford
that eight percent rate and so what's
happening now is that banks have losses
on all the assets that they own that
were interest rate sensitive they've got
you know hundreds of billions of dollars
I think the last number I saw was
something like 500 billion dollars
across the banking system just in terms
of their the the the assets that are
under water right now and what they're
trying to do is I either get rid of
those those assets or they're trying to
update their loan book in a way where
they're evolving the loan book away from
the three percent loan that they were
earning and
they're getting hopefully you know a
seven or eight percent loan that
replaces that and that way their net
interest margin can can maintain the
same margin they can just go on doing
their you know their their business the
way they always have it the you know the
old joke is you know borrow it at three
lend at six and be on the call golf golf
course by three
um you know that's what banks want to do
banks aren't like trying to do something
real sexy they're not trying to operate
the world world killing business like
you know a big you know high-flying tech
company would be they're trying to run a
very very simple business model and that
simple business model is broken right
now because there just isn't a lot of
demand at eight percent to make that
model sustainable so it's this is
especially true I think the big banks
have a lot less trouble with this
especially because they're the cost of
their liabilities is is very different
than a small Bank like I leave I I only
bank with Bank of America
um because I basically know like the
government will never let Bank of
America fail and all my money that I
leave in the bank account I try not to
leave a lot of money in the bank but you
know the money that I do leave in the
bank it's earning zero so the cost of my
liabilities to Bank of America are zero
um so it's this it's just weird
situation though where you know I also
have I have these golden handcuffs that
a lot of people talk about where we
refide at like I mean God I refined it
like two and a half percent back in you
know 2020 or whatever
um just an insane number and people talk
about how this is good for the
homeowners and yeah it's great for me
but somebody owns that somebody owns
that two and a half percent interest
bearing paper that in an inflationary
environment is underwater by you know
earlier this year it was underwater by
you know seven eight percent so you know
there's a flipped side to this and the
banks are on the flip side of all of
this where they own
or other financial institutions own that
two and a half percent paper from
millions of people like me who refide
back then and
you know that business model doesn't
hold up unless you're a Bank of America
or one of these big sort of globally
systemically important banks that the
government has really explicitly said
okay you know you're safe you're safe
you're safe you're safe there's like
eight of them and the problem is there's
4 500 banks in the United States and a
lot of those banks are really really
small Banks and so those really small
Banks they don't have the same luxury
that Bank of America does they have to
be able to go to their depositors and
say you know hey will you please stay
with us we'll offer you a four percent
rate on your short-term deposits and you
know the the net interest margin on that
sucks but hey it's better than us you
know going underwater and so to me
what's going on in the banking system is
it's evidence of this just much broader
problem the good news as it pertain
means to like a banking panic and the
FED is that the FED went through all of
this in 2008 so the FED kind of has this
tool kit that is sitting on the shelf
where when something happens with like
an svb or some sort of liquidity problem
they say oh yeah we remember you know
this four-letter acronym that saved this
group of the banking system let's just
reenact that and that's to a large
degree
that's what the FED is designed to do
the FED is designed to be an independent
intermediary they are literally the
Central Bank the you know they're not
just the Central Bank of the United
States they're the central bank for all
the banks so they're the intermediary
that when all of the other Banks break
if like let's say every Bank in the the
financial system breaks the FED comes in
and says okay look there's going to be a
lot of collateral damage from this if
Bank of America doesn't settle payments
with JP Morgan you know let's say that
you know I I'm purchasing stuff from
Anthony
um and Anthony and I bank at different
banks well you know our businesses could
be great businesses that are that have
no exposure to any you know downturn in
the economy or anything like that we're
just running these gangbuster businesses
but then all of a sudden our payments
might not clear between each other
because Bank of Bank of America and JP
Morgan run bad businesses and what the
FED is really designed to do is the
fed's designed to sit in the middle of
this and say look we're going to clear
the payments between these two entities
even though these two entities suck and
that way we'll Shield Anthony and Cullen
from having their own economic problems
like I'll never forget the story where
back in 2008 one of my very best friends
called me and he always relied on a
short-term line of credit from I think
it was Washington Mutual and he
he called me up and he was like dude my
business I might not be able to meet
payroll this week because Washington
Mutual won't process my payments and
this guy's this guy's running a business
that in a financial crisis actually does
really well so it was strange because I
knew this guy's business was doing
really well but his business was at risk
of failing potentially just because
Washington Mutual was a crappy bank and
that's that's the main goal the FED does
lots of lots of dumb stuff that's sort
of tangential to this but as a core
function as the intermediary who clears
payments the FED actually is the fed's
really really good at that they don't
get credit for it because nobody sees it
because the payment system processes
trillions of payments every day and
people just know that it works even as
like you know archaic as it might be or
as slow as it might be it works and even
in a period like 2008 it doesn't stop
working so it doesn't cause all this
collateral damage to people that had
nothing to do with the financial crisis
when you start looking at how these
consumers are behaving and then we start
talking about real estate and homes it
makes me think about the commercial real
estate market and not only the
commercial real estate market in terms
of uh the financial like um kind of
engineering that's gone on but one of
the big differences I think between 2020
and today uh compared to the global
financial crisis was if you looked at
the world before the global financial
crisis and you looked at the world maybe
a year or two after the global financial
crisis the only thing that really
changed was the financial markets right
but people still went to the same jobs
people still went and did all these
different things like their life didn't
change what they wanted to do didn't
really change if you look now before
covet hit everyone went into an office
now all of a sudden remote work is
dominant if you look at the geopolitical
kind of Fallout between Russia and
Ukraine like there's a war that then
disrupted all these Supply chains and
commodity prices and like like there's
fundamental changes to the world outside
of just the changes in the financial
markets and so how do you think about
a central bank or others having to not
only underwrite financial markets and
their and the decisions they're making
on the impact of those markets but they
also basically have to now become like
geopolitical experts they have to become
like labor force you know migration
experts and and there's all these other
moving targets outside of just like okay
prices were high prices crash we step in
prices go back and like all is good in
the world it feels like this is much
more complex of a situation than maybe
2008 was
yeah and it's
you know it's crazy because you know
especially with a lot of the like
political activism and stuff like I read
something I can't remember exactly what
it was a few months ago about how the
the Fed was starting to think about an
ESG mandate in the way that they manage
policy and it's like
dude you you can change the size of your
balance sheet and you can change
interest rates you're really not going
to have the capability your tools are so
blunt you're not going to have a
meaningful impact on climate change you
know and I'm not like against trying to
you know you know maintain a healthy
climate or anything it's just that this
is this is not the right entity through
which we should be trying to do
something like that and so in a lot of
ways like the system has become so
interconnected so globalized that and
you see this with the way that the FED
intervenes in crises where like you know
like the euro dollar market has become a
humongous Market it's you know by some
measures 12 trillion dollars this huge
Global dollar system though exists and
the FED is to a large degree responsible
for maintaining liquidity in that market
and they do this through typically by
issuing what are called swap lines
basically which are like synthetic
dollars to to non to other foreign Banks
but basically
you know they've become so
interconnected in all of this that
I think in a lot of ways we almost ask
too much of them that like in a perfect
world for me what would the Federal
Reserve be the Federal Reserve would be
this it would be a Clearing House it
would be almost basically like an
automated Clearinghouse that they do
they probably primarily serve that that
you know that core function of settling
payments between Bank of America and JP
Morgan and you know just for people who
who don't fully understand this the way
that banking basically operates is that
we bank at Banks and Banks bank at the
fed and so when Banks clear payments
um you know it's not just I don't just
send my deposits directly to Anthony the
way that that payment actually clears if
Anthony works or operates at a different
bank is the the banks actually send
reserves to one another so they send
Central Bank Reserves so they send their
deposits at the central bank to another
bank but from a so from a clearing
perspective the Fed is very good at that
and it's a mostly automated process they
don't have to get involved and you know
make a lot of discretionary decisions or
anything whereas things like
quantitative easing and changing
interest rates are much more
discretionary it is literally you know
12 people sitting at a table having a
meeting saying you know talking about
their you know the the Glory Days of the
1970s inflation or whatever it was and
you know stuff like that and then
deciding hey where should the interest
rate be and this sort of discretionary
interest rate management I think it just
it doesn't work very well because you
the driver of the vehicle is just too
involved in you know trying to steer
everything and if you can create a
system that's much more systematic in my
view you take a lot of these
responsibilities off of the fed's plate
where you know you could easily automate
interest rate management you could I
mean hell you could you could stick
interest rates at three percent and just
leave them forever if you wanted to
really
um that's not necessarily my view but
you know that could that that's how
simple the system could be some people I
know like the mmt people they want to
put interest rates at zero and leave
them at zero forever
um so there's automated ways of doing
this like you could Implement like
what's called a Taylor rule which is the
systematic equation to just set interest
rates in a very automated way I kind of
like something like that I'd I'd sort of
buffer it so that the Taylor rule tends
to have a lot of volatility in it like
the Taylor rule would have taken
interest rates to like 10 back in 2021
which I mean frankly I think that would
have that would have nuked to the
economy and the credit markets in a way
that yeah I would have it wouldn't have
caused or it would have snuffed out the
inflation faster than we did but it also
might have caused something really
really catastrophic with that sort of an
extreme jump from zero to ten like you
think you think banks are effed going
from zero to five if if we'd gone from
zero to ten in a year Banks the banks
would all I mean it wouldn't even be a
question of whether they're insolvent
they would all be involved in that
environment on a mark to Market basis so
you know my preference is that
we automate a lot more of this we we
stop worrying about like God like when I
watch one of these Jerome pal pressers
I'm just like like kill me this is
brutal like why are we sitting around
waiting on this guy who whose entire
career experience is mostly like the 60s
and 70s
economies who maybe doesn't even have
any really solid understanding of things
like cryptocurrency markets and you know
Ai and new technologies and geopolitical
events that are having really really big
impacts on the way that all of this
works rather than just automating a lot
of this stuff in a way where it's
systematic you know non-discretionary
um you know not necessarily perfectly
decentralized but at least decentralized
in a way where we're we're
decentralizing it away from 12 people
who just have phds in economics and sit
around and theorize about where this may
or may not go so
to answer the question I just I think we
ask way too much of the FED they have
super blunt instruments there's no way
they can manage all the geopolitical
risks and the the climate risks and all
the political stuff that you know we
demand from them and so I would if I was
King of the United States I would
probably one of the first things I'd
probably do is go into the fed and say
you know Whittle down you know hey how
much of this can we can we reduce to the
point where this is basically you know
like chat GPT is basically running
monetary policy
when you start looking at things like uh
Bitcoin as an example right which don't
have that human-led monetary policy
again there's a whole bunch of other
things that go into Bitcoin but just
take as one thing that it does have is
this programmatic monetary policy versus
human-led whether it is the Bitcoin
programmatic monetary policy or chat gbt
or you know name your way to get there
is there an argument to be made that
actually that would be better than the
human-led policy
oh yeah I I think 100 I mean any any
sort of systematic
um approach to this I think would be
superior to I mean I
a lot of this is my experience not just
in in having you know talked to either
policy makers or
um or policy theorists and macro
economists about a lot of this stuff but
also coming at this from a market
perspective like I know
I mean look I I think I think I'm a
pretty smart guy I think I've spent my
entire adult life trying to understand
financial markets and the macro economy
and I'll be the first person to tell you
I I know so much less than I thought I
did back you know when I started this
adventure it's almost like the more you
learn the more you realize how complex
all of this is to the point where it's
like holy does anybody really
understand how any of this stuff works
because I mean especially when you start
talking to lay people it's like you know
as soon as you start talking about
things like quantitative easing and you
know Central Bank Reserves it's like
they're like I'm sorry what are you
speaking Mandarin to me or like you know
and so the the experts or the so-called
experts
know that this stuff is ex it's so
extraordinary complex to the point where
I think we worry that like we don't even
understand exactly what's going on
that I kind of know especially with
portfolio management like the more you
can take the human element out of this
stuff the better it operates and so like
I mean like we run an ETF that is it's a
pure algorithm I have I built the
algorithm but like
you know that fund it it involves zero
of me going you know which direction is
GDP gonna go this year there is nothing
involved in that is just a programmatic
uh model that the model has data that
goes in it spits out data and that is
the asset allocation that we use and I
think that's sort of a systematic
approach not only to
um to investing but to monetary policy
especially is it's so much more
efficient because you take out you take
out the tail risk really in the human
decision-making process where you know
going back to the car analogy
you take out the risk of you know oh the
human looks down at their phone for one
second and all of a sudden they're
driving into a telephone pole you know
you take out that asymmetric risk of you
know hey I made a I made one bad
decision that was a pretty minor
decision in the grand scheme of things
that had a catastrophic outcome and just
non-discretionary systems I think just
in general they reduce a lot of that the
human tail risk error that a lot of us
see either in managing our own finances
or you know managing policy over time
when you start to look at moving forward
what do you think is
um other than like some sort of like
programmatic you know uh type uh
monetary policy like what do you think
could be done to improve the lives of
individuals and also maybe the business
environment like one of the things I'm
very focused on is uh how do we
regenerate economic growth how do we
make sure that people continue to your
point you know the quality of life
continues to increase
what could be done or what what are you
looking at what would you like to see
done uh in kind of a macro environment
that would be conducive to that stuff
occurring
Ah that's a really really hard question
um
in terms of are you talking like
government policy specifically it could
be government policy it could be
Treasury and fed related it could be
um maybe it's actually the opposite
maybe it's like get rid of a bunch of
policy and legislation like it you know
I always come at this from um all of
these things we're talking about even
monetary policy in my mind is a carrot
and a stick right in some cases
obviously ultra low uh interest rates is
very much a carrot it's like hey come on
in right bring all the people come
borrow come come and do this but then
there's this stick capability which kind
of if you look at a drone power going
from zero to five percent interest rate
so like he was kind of smacking everyone
and saying hey knock it off right and so
you can go across uh kind of the economy
and maybe even a larger society and say
there are all these carrots and sticks
that can be used for incentives one of
the most direct examples I think is this
idea of
um kind of the opportunity zones in real
estate but guess what they did is they
opened up opportunity zones what did
people do they said thank you very much
and they went they poured Capital into
those areas you can debate whether they
should have done it not done it you
could debate where they picked the areas
whatever uh you know how long the time
period was what the treatment of the
taxes like all that stuff for debate but
it is very clear that they created a new
rule that new rule had the impact that
they wanted which was they got Capital
into these areas and so if we look at
okay what we want to occur in the
economy or in society like what are the
things what are the levers we can pull
right as carrots or sticks to actually
incentivize that stuff to happen
gosh so I mean you're asking for like my
uh my presidential platform sure which
by the way I I left DC
20 years ago and I'm in San Diego now
and I hope I never have to go back for
anything policy related reason ever but
um
God I
I mean going back to Fed policy that's
the that's sort of the one that's always
just so front and center because the FED
is so involved in everything in the
media like I think you could you could
automate so much of fed policy that
there's
you need people you need boots on the
ground in the FED to some degree because
there's just you know people need to be
involved in you know the the policies to
some degree
um so you can't fully make it
non-discretionary but I think you could
I think you could remove a huge amount
of the discretion by making things
relatively systematic
um I mean in terms of policy
like or other policies like
um I would simplify a ton of government
policy like
um we were talking before we jumped on
that like I I was super involved in
building my own home and
um like I was putting on a work belt
every day like because my day basically
ends at like two or three o'clock
because the markets close early here and
you know back when I was building my
house I was basically I was putting on a
work belt every single day you know and
I was I was jumping on the roof and I
was you know I was ruining new boots
every month and
I was super involved but one of the
lessons from that was that the
permitting process working with the
government on it was it was brutal and
like my wife is super super liberal and
and I'm pretty moderate for the most
part I try to I'm actually like I don't
know I'm I'm almost like a chameleon in
the sense that like as the environment
changes I kind of view myself as someone
who you know typically when the economy
is booming I become more conservative
and when the economy busts I I tend to
become a little bit more of a Democrat
typically
um so on average because booms are the
majority of what we experience I'm I
tend to probably lean maybe a little bit
more conservative on average but I am
sort of a chameleon in a political
perspective but I mean going through
that permitting process it was brutal
and the rules are the red tape there's
so much they make things so difficult
and so unnecessarily difficult that and
you see this in things like like man the
tax code the tax code in this country is
a friggin disaster it's so much more
complex and they keep adding on new
rules thinking that like you know oh we
need a wealth tax now and I think
politicians think of this as like
Innovation this is like their way of
like doing things that are like
Innovative and hey we came up with this
great new idea and it's like dude you're
not making anyone's life easier like all
this stuff like what are we going to do
with a wealth tax are we going to have
IRS agents go into everybody's house and
say that painting is worth twenty
thousand dollars you know that chair
you're sitting in is worth a thousand
dollars like it's just it's an absurd
concept when you think of it at like an
operational level and I think a lot of
these things have become so much more
complex than they need to that
I mean you could probably roll back tons
of these rules and simplify things that
um it would make people's lives
massively easier because that's I mean
that's part of the problem with Modern
Life is that you know I see it now with
with two young kids
um
it's it's really it's a lot there's just
the world has become so complex and a
lot of that is just our own doing that
like we demand too much from ourselves
and parents demand too much from their
kids and you know it put a lot of
pressure on ourselves to to do things
that we we just frankly shouldn't but at
the same time I think the government
makes a lot of this more difficult
because the the red tape and the
regulations have become so hard to
overcome and we're trying to solve so
many problems with like blunt
instruments that
um
it's become really counterproductive so
I would probably I would roll back
I had tons of regulations across
different Industries and
um and try to just simplify things the
best that we could because life is
getting more difficult it's going to
become more difficult especially as like
you see this a lot with like the
technological changes that like people
are going to have a lot of trouble
adapting to this new world where like
you know we're in I mean God when my
kids are adults they're probably going
to have you know robot James is going to
be making their dinner for them in the
kitchen using you know a an AI based
understanding of what's going on in the
kitchen and it's like you know things
like that
the world is about to become even more
complex even more interconnected people
are trying to like I think de-globalize
the world and it's like to me it's like
this is a one-way train where you you
can't de-globalize all of this because
it's becoming so much more
interconnected in large part through
technology that it is it it's an
inescapable reality of our future and
that just makes everything much more
complex so the the degree to which we
can simplify the way that the government
is involved in all of this I think would
massively improve living standards
because right now a lot of the stuff
they're doing is just I think it's
making things so much more complex which
makes it just more difficult for
everybody to navigate what is already an
increasingly complex world
I tend to agree with you my last
question for you is what are you doing
from an investment allocation standpoint
are there changes that you're making Are
there specific focuses like when
somebody asks you kind of you know what
do you own right how do you think about
your portfolio today
yeah I mean
this is obviously like a super personal
question I I tend to work with I mean
most of my clients are really
conservative people so tend to be older
retiree types that they come to me
because I don't do anything super sexy
like I'm not I'm not I mean I'm
personally involved in like VC and
crypto but like for my clients they're
people that really they don't really
want to be involved in any they don't
want to be involved in anything that's
doing this you know so like for for my
business and my clients right now I mean
God I can remember back 20 years ago
this is the first time where you could
buy treasury bills we can buy treasury
bills right now for five and a half
percent
um which you couldn't do that at any
point in the last like 20 years I
remember I mean when my career was
starting that was basically the last
time that you could do that and so you
know you're finally getting I know you
know treasury bills are like the least
sexy
um instrument in the world oral but I
mean geez if you're you got a million
bucks you put it all in treasury bills
you're making fifty thousand dollars a
year for for doing nothing I mean not
that you should necessarily put all your
money in treasury bills but as a as an
asset allocation component you know cash
right now is is
it's as sexy as it's been in decades but
in terms of like actual asset allocation
I really like to think in really in time
Horizons I mean I build my portfolio in
a very specific temporal perspective
meaning that like I typically think of
things like like Bitcoin and my model is
it's a multi-multi-decade instrument
it's hyper volatile but in the long run
it's likely to generate value but you've
got to be super super patient with it
stocks are basically the same sort of
thing where if you look at stocks on
like a multi-decade period in over a
20-year period stocks are in my model
stocks are basically an 18-year
instrument that will generate something
like five to seven percent per year so
you can think of them almost like a
super long duration bond that generates
a much better yield than say like a
30-year treasury bond and then you've
got all these other instruments that it
kind of intermediate get treasury bills
or you know they're super short-term
instruments they're cash-like
equivalents basically that generate
right now they generate five which is
phenomenal and then you've got all the
stuff in you know the intermediate
instruments that are like you know
whether it's intermediate corporate
bonds or whatever and so I've kind of
blocked my portfolio in a very
specific way where I cover
what are essentially my future expected
liabilities where I try not to hold too
much cash or short-term stuff but I also
know like
you know I've got young kids that are
you know they're both the the second
one's going to daycare in two weeks and
that daycare is it's expensive
um so I've blocked out you know a Year's
worth of basically cash to cover you
know both of my kids uh daycare needs
over the course of the next year and I
do that across everything to the point
where you know like for my retirement
money my retirement money is it's
technically it's super aggressive
um so it's more like you know it's more
like VC or
um or crypto or you know I I own you
know a huge allocation in the equity
markets
um but it's all blocked in a very
specific temporal framework where I'm
protected not just from an acid
allocation and diversification
perspective but I'm really planning
across specific time Horizons where I've
I've blocked things in this very sort of
specific manner where I kind of know
like over the course of the next 30 40
years
I've got money for all time Horizons so
it's a
it's not just I not only think of it as
like an all-weather approach meaning
that like it it has components that are
able to weather all environments whether
it's inflation or deflation or whatever
it is it's it I call it all duration
investing specifically because it covers
all time Horizons and to me I mean
that just gives me a lot of it gives me
a lot of certainty so I sleep well at
night because I just know hey I've got
if the hits the fan tomorrow I know
that I've got you know a million bucks
sitting in treasury bills that are there
and I don't have to worry about being
able to afford stuff for the next you
know three years
so that's kind of how I think about an
asset allocation framework which is a
little different from like uh what
people would call like a modern
portfolio Theory where they sort of just
most asset managers kind of like take
they take a pool of assets and they try
to figure out basically the best way
that all these assets kind of work uh in
tandem with each other to generate the
most efficient return and I don't really
care how efficient you know on uh you
know on some sort of modern portfolio
Theory perspective my portfolio is I
want to know do I have money for this
time Horizon and are these assets likely
to grow you know the are the longer
duration instruments likely to grow in a
way where I've got money when I get to
that time Horizon
I think very similarly to you in that uh
there's an amount of money and I want to
be able to cover expenses for a period
of time then there's like a risk bucket
and that obviously is things that I want
to buy and hold for a really long time
and then there's things that I kind of
want to take a little bit of risk but I
want to be able to access on a shorter
time Horizon and uh it makes you feel a
little bit more bulletproof I think
right of just like you have optionality
and you're prepared for a lot of
different situations yeah you know the
the thing is is it you know I use this
term behaviorally robust investing a lot
where you want to make your portfolio
super behaviorally robust where like
there are really strong Arguments for
being like you know a hundred percent
Bitcoin or a hundred percent stocks you
know in the long run and the problem
with that is that you know life life is
a Time problem and we all have to
navigate the short term and the problem
is when you create a portfolio that is
ultra Ultra aggressive you create an
asset liability mismatch you create
basically a temporal mismatch and that's
if I mean it's funny talking about the
banks in this situation because that's
exactly what the banks did the banks
bought super long duration bonds and
then they found out when interest rates
went up well in a one or two year time
Horizon that portfolio is way underwater
and then on a mark to Market basis they
don't have the liquidity they need to be
able to meet outflows or whatever it is
they need and they have this massive
asset liability mismatch and they just
they didn't manage the time Horizon of
their portfolio well well and now that's
the worst thing that can happen to an
investor is you get forced out of a
position you never want to be forced out
of a position against your will you
never want to be forced to sell your
20-year stock position because you
bought more than you could afford to
manage your short-term liabilities
you never want to be forced out of a
position that's a great place for us to
end call it I always enjoy talking to
you I learned so much uh where can we
send people to find you on the internet
or find out more about discipline funds
yeah I'm on Twitter at uh Cullen roach
and um
disciplinefunds.com I I write a
newsletter discipline alerts and we talk
about you know things that are going on
in the macro economy I talk a lot about
the the guts of how the system works and
you know kind of similar to what we were
talking about today trying to explain
things from more of a a little bit of a
first principles perspective where it's
like okay you know what is the debt
ceiling does it make sense should you
freak out about it and sell all of your
financial assets or you know is this you
know is this a better understanding a
better framework to understand this so
you can put this in perspective so that
you understand kind of the the potential
risks of different outcomes
I think that's a great place for uh
people to go check it out uh you're a
fantastic follow on Twitter I always
appreciate you putting content out there
and we will definitely do this again in
the future yeah you too for sure Anthony
appreciate you man